to present the Writing Awards the
Academy has invited some of America's
most distinguished authors over the
years
Tennessee Williams James Michener gore
Vidal Norman Mailer despite my own many
books I didn't think I should handle it
this year instead here's a man who made
TV drama worth watching and then wrote
for Broadway hits he's no stranger to
this stage but this is his first
appearance for the wings because in the
past he arrived from the audience he did
it three times to pick up Oscars for the
screenplays of Marty the hospital and
last year Network ladies and gentlemen
paddy Chayefsky
before I get onto the Writing Awards
there's a little matter I'd like to tidy
up at least if I expect to live with
myself tomorrow morning I would like to
say personal opinion of course that I'm
sick and tired of people exploiting the
occasion of the Academy Awards
for the propagation of their own
personal political propaganda
I would like to suggest to miss Redgrave
that her winning an Academy Award is not
a pivotal moment in history does not
require a proclamation and a simple
thank you would have sufficed
and now want a much more important
matters screenplay writing is a much
misunderstood form of writing in the old
days the the image of the screenwriter
was that of the great novelist who had
gone derelict in the corrupt tropics of
Hollywood and nowadays I think they
think of the screenwriter frequently if
somebody helps out the director with
lines of dialogue but in point the fact
screenwriting is a very special highly
refined discipline it requires all the
standard storytelling talents and it
also requires a visual eye as well
because the screenwriter frequently has
to tell a story without words which are
after all the primary tools of the
writers craft when it works a good
screenplay is a thing of beauty a model
of precision and clarity and imagery and
concept and mobility wit passion there's
a something to celebrate and something
to honor and so let's honor them oh I've
got to read the nominees
I'm glad II get to know I must say every
one of these foes are friends of mine
the nominees for the original screenplay
awards are Woody Allen and Marshall
Brickman for Annie Hall Neil Simon for
the goodbye girl
Robert Benton for the Late Show
George Lucas for Star Wars Arthur
Laurents
for the turning point
and the winner is Woody Allen Marshall
accepting the award for woody
himself mr. Marco Brickman
thank you it's very nice it's very nice
I hope we have enough time so that I can
say that half of slope peace of ten if
not much more belongs to woody who is
probably the greatest collaborator
anybody could ever wish for he does a
lot of brilliant work he takes our
script and makes it into what you saw
he picks up my lunch check for about
five months and then on April 4th April
3rd he refuses to come out of his
apartment thanks also to Gordie Willis
for his wonderful photography for Keaton
for obvious reasons Diane that is and to
the boys in the backroom author and Eric
and Bill and Bob and Marcia and Mike for
their continued support and benign
neglect which is the key to our success
and you've all been very kind and I must
confess the only problem is I've been
out here a week and I still have guilt
when I make a right turn on a red light
maybe this
in the category of screenplays based on
material from another medium the
nominees are Equus screenplay by Peter
Shaffer I never promised you a rose
garden screenplay by Gavin Lambert and
Lewis John collee no Julia screenplay by
Alvin Sargent Oh God screenplay by Larry
Gelbart that obscure object of desire
screenplay by Liu even well in John
Claude Cathy air and the winner is Alvin
Sargent
thank you thank you through a lot of
people Fred Zinnemann everybody at 20th
Century Fox who took the chance and
allowed us to make this film to the
wonderful actors Jane and Vanessa jason
maximilian schell everyone else to
Richard Roth a remarkable friend and
producer of mine and one other person
who is more responsible for this than
anyone else and that is a lady whose
name or was called Julia and for all the
things that she stands for I like to
think that this Oscar represents the
those things and the free expression of
all our good thoughts and feelings and
loves no matter who we are or what we
have to say and to Julia's dear friend
Lillian Hellman
who who wrote the best words first thank
you very much
you